I’ve been fascinated with quantum physics for a
very long time so much so I did a PhD in it and
I wanted to share the subject with you so I made
this map of quantum physics to lay out the ideas
within the subject, to set some bounds on it so
you know its not endless and to introduce you
to lots of concepts that if you are interested in
them you can dig deeper. When you are approaching
a subject like this that’s so complicated
it can be quite challenging because you
don’t know where to start and you don’t know
how all the concepts relate to each other so
hopefully this will put everything in context.
Okay first lets just look at the geography of this
map to the north west we have the foundations
of quantum physics, and then travelling further
south we go through quantum phenomena to quantum
technology. And in the south and east we have the
academic disciplines of quantum physics. In the
centre, quantum theory, and in the north and east
the theoretical future of quantum physics,
beyond what we already know. That is your
quantum forecast for this video. I’ve also made a
poster of this available so if that’s of interest,
check it out in the description below. And
without further ado, let’s get into it.
The theory of quantum mechanics developed from a
set of mysteries in the late 1800s and early 1900s
where reality didn’t quite match
the models of physics at the time.
We now call these older theories of physics,
classical physics. There were several clues
that pointed to some deeper model of reality.
When light shines through a gas, the gas absorbs
and emits specific frequencies of light which we
call atomic spectra. This was a mystery there was
no known classical explanation for this.
And there was a lot of confusion about how
atoms could be stable. In classical physics
the electrons should continually radiate
their energy and collapse into the nucleus.
The source of radioactivity was unknown.
When you look at a hot body like the Sun,
it emits electromagnetic radiation in many
different frequencies and this distribution
of light is called blackbody radiation.
Now the distribution we observe
from black bodies didn’t match
the predictions of classical physics.
And when you shine light on certain metals,
you can make electrons fly off, this is
called the photoelectric effect. This
experiment showed that light didn’t behave like
a wave, but like a stream of particles and was
the first indication of particle wave duality.
All of these mysteries can only be explained with
the laws of quantum mechanics.
Let’s take a look at the
foundations of quantum mechanics.
A cornerstone experiment in quantum
mechanics is the double slit experiment where
electrons are fired through two thin slits and
make an interference pattern on a detector behind.
This interference pattern is something you only
see with waves and this is more experimental
evidence for particle wave-duality.
In actual fact, in the mathematics of quantum
mechanics all particles are described as waves
by a thing called a wavefunction, and the way this
wave evolves over time is described by the famous
Shrodinger equation. But we can never see these
quantum waves as all we ever detect are particles,
but from the wave function we can predict
where the particles are likely to turn up
but we have to do a bit of maths
on them first called the Born rule
which derives a probability distribution of where
the particle might be from the wavefunction.
So quantum mechanics tells us that the universe is
fundamentally probabilistic, we don’t know exactly
where the particle will turn up the best we have
is a probability of where it will be. This brings
us to the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
which says that quantum objects don’t have
definite values for certain pairs of properties,
for example, position and momentum. You can get
a flavour of this from these pictures. The first
is a snapshot where the particle had a definite
position, but we have no information about its
momentum, as in: the direction it was going and
how fast it was travelling. The second picture has
a motion blur which tells us about its momentum,
but now we have got an uncertainty about where
the particle was when we took the picture.
Another important equation is the Dirac
equation which extends the Schrodinger equation
to include special relativity and describe
particles with high kinetic energy. And another
important foundational concept is Bell’s theorem
which proved that the uncertainty in quantum
mechanics is not caused by our lack of knowledge
about hidden variables, but is a fundamental part
of the universe, and also led to the concept of
non-locality which we’ll meet a little later.
Finally we get to energy quantization
which is where objects like electrons
can only have certain definite energies when
they are in atoms. This is where the quantum
in quantum mechanics comes from. And this
quantization is because their wave functions
can only vibrate in certain specific ways.
You can see this if I reduce the atom to one
dimension. The energy field of the proton in
the atom is represented by this bucket shape,
you can think of the electron as being attracted
to the proton and so it wants to fall into the
bottom of the bucket. But because the electron
is a wave it can only exist in certain modes
shown here which are just like the vibrational
modes of a guitar string, with higher frequency
modes having a higher energy.
This also means that the quantum
objects always have a minimum amount of
energy known as the zero-point energy,
and this applies not only to electrons in atoms,
but to everything, even to empty space itself.
Now I understand that this is all quite
a lot to take in if you are new to this.
But don’t worry if all these terms are
confusing, the point of this video is to expose
you to a lot of the concepts in quantum
physics just so that you know they exist.
I can’t delve into every one otherwise we’d be
here forever. But if you want to dig deeper into
any of these concepts I’ve made a playlist
of other videos that covers a lot of them.
There however are a lot of gaps though, and
I’m planning on filling them in in the future,
so if you want to make sure you don’t miss
out consider subscribing to this channel
for more details in the future.
Okay let's carry on and take a look
at the interesting properties we see in
quantum systems with quantum phenomena.
Particles in quantum mechanics have
many properties. I’ve already mentioned
position and momentum, but there are
others which I’ve listed here.
Spin is a very important property and all
particles are split into one of two categories,
bosons which have got an integer spin
and can all have the same quantum state,
and fermions, which have half integer spin and
can’t have the same quantum state as each other,
which is called the Pauli exclusion principle.
Superposition is a property when a particle has a
probability of being in many different states, for
example, two different places at the same time.
This simply means that it’s wavefunction
has values in two different places,
although when you measure it it will turn up
in just one place. Being in multiple places at
once is confusing if we think of particles, but
is completely natural when we think of waves,
for example any point on the surface of the ocean
is a superposition of thousands of waves.
You may have heard of Schrodinger's Cat is a
popular description of superposition, although not
a very helpful one as it was originally designed
to show how absurd quantum mechanics seems
as cat’s can’t be alive and dead at the same time.
Which is true, but not because superposition is
not real, we now know large things like cats loose
their quantum behaviour because of decoherence.
Decoherence happens when a quantum object
interacts with an environment and its quantum
behaviour is lost to that environment. Decoherence
is what takes us from the quantum realm to the
world that we inhabit, and you break the coherence
of quantum objects when you make a measurement.
Entanglement is where the wavefunction of
the two or more particles interact and mix
causing them to become a single quantum object.
This means that the properties of the different
particles will be correlated even if they
are separated a large distance. This concept,
where the wavefunction that describes a particle
is spread far away from the particle is known as
non-locality, and is another thing that doesn’t
happen in the world that we experience.
There are several other interesting phenomena
which only happen in quantum systems which
include: quantum tunnelling - the ability for
particles to cross narrow barriers because their
wavefunction penetrates through. Superconductivity
- the ability for electrons to move with zero
resistance at low temperatures, and superfluidity
- allowing fluids to flow with zero viscosity.
There’s also the quantum hall effect which is
the quantisation of conductance in 2D materials,
and the casimir effect which is an
attractive force at short distances
caused by cutting out large quantum waves
between two plates. An important concept
when looking at the quantum behaviour of
large systems are phase transitions from
one collective behaviour to another. These are
analogous to the different phases of matter,
solid, liquid and gas but in quantum phase
transitions it is not only temperature and
pressure that plays an important role it
can also be applied magnetic field.
Whenever we discover new interesting
behaviours in physics, one of the first
questions is can we use this to develop
some new interesting technology?
And there is a lot of technology that we use
every day which takes advantage of the amazing
properties of quantum systems. Lasers use a
process called stimulated emission to create
beams of light with many photons which
all have the same frequency and phase.
Atomic clocks keep incredibly accurate time
by using the frequency of light from a very
specific hyperfine transition in caesium atoms and
are the basis of our global positioning system.
The band theory of solids describes the energy
levels of electrons in different solid materials
and is the basis of the semiconductor industry
which has yielded many different technologies
solid state transistors, so basically the
building block of every computer in the world,
LEDs which you are probably using to watch
this, CCD’s used in every digital camera
and solar panels turning the energy
in sunlight into electricity.
Electron microscopes, scanning tunneling
microscopes and atomic force microscopes
allow us to see objects we can’t see with
optical microscopes because they can see
smaller than the wavelength of visible light
to resolve objects like viruses or atoms.
And magnetic resonance imaging techniques are
used in biology and chemistry, for example
to look inside our bodies, and these use giant
superconducting magnets to create large magnetic
fields, and the most sensitive magnetic sensors
in the world called superconducting quantum
interference devices (SQUIDs) whose core
components are a loop of superconducting wire
which contain an insulating gap
called a Josephson junction.
New technologies are being built and
improved in the world of quantum information.
Quantum cryptography takes advantage of
entanglement to make communication which
is extremely secure and forms the basis of the
quantum internet. And quantum teleportation is
the ability to perfectly copy the quantum state
of an object from one location to another.
Quantum bits or qubits are the building blocks
of quantum computers which use superposition and
entanglement to create states that are practically
impossible to simulate on a classical computer.
The challenge is to engineer large groups of
qubits that can stay coherent for long enough to
perform their computations which is not an easy
task. But the potential is huge because their
combined superposition means they can explore an
exponential number of states at the same time.
This puts them in a different complexity class
to the classical computers we use every day.
There are many exciting applications of quantum
computers but my favourite is quantum simulation:
the ability to simulate a quantum system
which would be amazing for things like
discovering new materials with entirely new
properties or for solving computationally
expensive tasks like protein folding.
Now let's move on to the fields of quantum
physics research. These include condensed matter
physics, quantum biology, cold atom physics,
quantum chemistry, nuclear physics,
particle physics and theoretical physics.
Condensed matter physics is the study of large
systems of many atoms in solid or liquid form,
and seeking to understand their collective
behaviour on a quantum level.
I've placed this here because condensed matter
physics covers a lot of these other fields
and condensed matter theory describes the
quantum behaviour of collections of electrons
in solids which explains collective
behaviours like superconductivity,
and the energy bands of semiconductors.
There are many unsolved problems in condensed
matter physics, for example, we still don't
have a theoretical model that explains how
high-temperature superconductivity works.
In a way the frontier of condensed matter
physics is complexity. Because the subject
studies complex combinations of many atoms
which make many different materials with
different physical and electronic properties,
the potential avenues for study are basically
endless because the combinations are endless.
Quantum biology studies the role that quantum
mechanics has in biological systems. There are
many processes in biology that are difficult
to explain without quantum mechanics being
involved, like the efficiency of energy transport
in photosynthesis, to magneto-reception in birds,
how our sense of smell and sight work, and
how enzymes speed up chemical reactions.
Cold atom physics evolved from condensed matter
physics and studies gasses which are controlled
in magnetic or optical traps and cooled to
ultra-low temperatures using laser cooling
and other cooling techniques.
Cold atom physics studies many exotic
phases of matter like Bose-Einstein Condensates
and Rydberg matter, and looks at their behaviour
like quantum phase transitions, quantum spin
systems and many more. Cold atom experiments
can also be used as quantum simulators and
quantum sensors like gravity sensors.
Because quantum mechanics describes the behaviour
of electrons in atoms, it also describes the basic
rules of chemistry. The Schrodinger equation is
used to describe electronic structure of atoms
and how molecules are bonded and move called
molecular dynamics. Solving the quantum mechanics
of molecules is a very computationally intensive
task and so computational techniques are very
important to quantum chemistry a popular approach
is a method called quantum monte carlo.
Nuclear physics is the study of the nucleus
of the atom and the ways nuclei can join in
nuclear fusion or split apart in nuclear
fission, and the particles and energy
involved in these nuclear reactions.
Applications of nuclear physics include
nuclear power, nuclear weapons, nuclear
medicine, and techniques such as MRI,
ion implantation and radiocarbon dating.
Particle physics evolved from nuclear physics
and is focused on understanding what the
fundamental particles of the universe are
and how they interact. Experiments in particle
physics are performed in large particle
accelerators where high energy particles
are smashed together to make new particles
out of the collision energy. This is why this
field is also known as high energy physics.
The standard model of particle physics describes
all of the fundamental particles we know of,
which we’ve discovered over many decades,
the last of which was the Higgs boson.
A useful tool for visualising particle
interactions are Feynman diagrams which
show what happens when particles collide
and they simplify the equations of quantum
field theory into much simpler pictures.
The theories of the standard model include
quantum electrodynamics which describes
the electromagnetic force. Electroweak
interactions which include the weak force,
and quantum chromodynamics which
also describes the strong force.
In the standard model, these are all quantum
field theories where particles are understood
to be excitations of quantum fields which also
govern how they interact with each other.
There may be other particles out there that we
haven’t discovered yet. People have proposed
that dark matter might be made of particles
called weakly interacting massive particles,
and the large discrepancy between the weak force
and gravity known as the hierarchy problem may
be solved by supersymmetric particles.
So the frontier of particle physics is to
try and work out new ways to explore the landscape
of potential particles at very high energies.
Now onto the field of quantum theory
which, although I’ve put it in this box,
it really covers this whole map with specific
implementations in each of the fields.
Here are some specific aspects of
quantum theory worth knowing about.
The core of quantum physics are the postulates of
quantum mechanics that set the ground rules.
The path integral formulation of quantum
mechanics is a very elegant way of calculating
the motion of particles by integrating over every
possible path that the particle can take.
And Hilbert spaces are a useful tool to describe
all of the possible states of a quantum system,
in a giant multidimensional space.
The symmetries of quantum mechanics are
an important part of the theory to tell us the
conservation rules which are basically the rules
of particle interactions: what should come out of
a particle interaction based on what goes in.
This is where we hit the limits of our current
knowledge of quantum physics. But there are two
main areas of theoretical work looking beyond
the existing models. Firstly the interpretations
of quantum mechanics are attempts to resolve the
counterintuitive implications of the wavefunction,
and quantum gravity aims to reconcile quantum
field theory with general relativity to make
a grand theory of everything.
The core of the interpretations of
quantum mechanics is the measurement problem.
When we make a measurement on a quantum object
it’s wavefunction suddenly changes when we
detect the particle. And the laws of quantum
mechanics don’t contain any explanation of what
is actually happening to the wavefunction at the
instant of measurement. We also don’t know
if the wavefunction is actually real or not.
And these conceptual problems in quantum
mechanics are what the interpretations of quantum
mechanics attempt to explain.
For many years the default approach
was the Copenhagen interpretation, but other
popular interpretations include pilot wave theory,
the many worlds interpretation and quantum
bayesianism and many others. It is too
much to get into all of them, but I’ve made
another video which covers this ground.
They are called interpretations because
we don’t yet have any experiments to tell
which ones are real and which are not, so
really they are a collection of interesting
ideas rather than proper physical theories.
Quantum field theory is the most comprehensive
description of reality we have, combining
quantum mechanics with special relativity.
But we know it is not a complete description as it
doesn’t include general relativity and gravity.
There are many attempts to merge quantum
mechanics and general relativity into a
grand unified theory everything and the two
main candidates are string theory and loop
quantum gravity. String theory is also known
as M-theory which is a theory that unites all
different consistent versions of string theory.
It is very difficult to test the theories of
quantum gravity because you need to go
to such high energies, you would need
to build a particle accelerator like the large
hadron collider, but the diameter of the solar
system with detectors the size of jupiter.
So currently, the best hope we have of signatures
of quantum gravity are from observing high energy
processes in the universe: signatures from the big
bang or black holes might give us some clues
and this is an active area of research.
So that’s it, that’s all of quantum physics.
Congratulations you’ve got to the end.
Obviously this is a lot to take in so don’t worry
if you didn’t get it all at a first pass. But
you can always watch it again or grab this
image for a reference in the future.
This part of the video was sponsored by Brilliant,
and if this video has made you want to learn more
about quantum physics or get better at maths
and science in general Brilliant is a fantastic
resource. It is a website with many courses
where you learn and solve problems at your
own pace. They have a whole section dedicated to
quantum physics and actively learning by solving
problems means that you learn the material a lot
more thoroughly than just watching videos because
nothing challenges your understanding than
a good question. As I have found many times.
So this is a simple, fun way to keep learning
more. If that sounds interesting go to brilliant
dot org slash dos or click on the link in the
description below which helps me out as they know
you’ve come from here, and the first 200 people
to do so will get 20% off the annual subscription
which unlocks all of their premium content.
Also as I mentioned at the beginning of the video,
I’m selling this map as a poster
which you can find on my DFTBA
store and a big shoutout to everyone who gave
me feedback on twitter, and a special thanks to
@physgal and @chriferrie for their input.
And if you’d like to support my work I have
a patreon page as well. In any case I’ll be
here making more videos aiming to make science
easier to understand. Sp thanks again
for watching and I’ll see you soon!